[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau débat proposé par les rédactions
de tv 78 radio sensations pour le
premier tour des élections municipales
ce soir quatre candidats sont en plateau
avec moi ils prétendent tous devenir ou
rester pour l'un d'entre eux maire de
saint germain en laye durant la
prochaine heure il doit exposer leur
projet sur des thématiques variées et
déjà fixé parmi elles l'environnement et
la culture leur temps de parole seront
évidemment chronométré pour assurer
l'équité et un tirage au sort a été
effectué pour fixer l'ordre de la
première prise de parole
kane et richard vous avez été choisi
pour vous exprimer en premier tête de
liste saint germain écologique et
solidaire c'est votre première
expérience électorale en tant que
candidat soutenu par un grand nombre de
partis de gauche dont le ps parti
socialiste europe écologie les verts le
parti communiste dans la vie vous êtes
ingénieur des services culturels et du
patrimoine pourquoi les saint germanois
doivent-ils voté pour vous le 15 mars
alors j'ai été désigné donc par un
collectif de citoyennes et de citoyens
qui s'appelle collectif de citoyens de
gauche à l'origine donc pour mener une
liste saint germain écologique et
solidaire
je dirais la différence par rapport aux
autres candidats
c'est que ça tisse ne s'est pas fait
autour d'une personne mais c'est bien un
collectif qui a désigné en son sein une
personne pour porter des idées des
valeurs nous nos trois valeurs sont la
transition écologique dans un contexte
d'urgence climatique
l'équité sociale ce qu'on croit que
chacun doit avoir accès à l'ensemble des
services proposés par la municipalité et
enfin la démocratie pour garantir une
participation effective des citoyennes à
la vie locale
christophe bentz tête de liste audace
pour saint germain vous êtes délégué
général du parti chrétien démocrate
parti présidé aujourd'hui par
jean-frédéric poisson ancien candidat à
la présidentielle vous êtes aussi un
proche de marion maréchal-le pen avec
laquelle vous avez créé une école de
sciences politiques à lyon en 2017 vous
étiez candidat sur la 6e circonscription
des yvelines vous aviez récolté 2 % des
suffrages à peu près pour ces
municipales vous êtes soutenus notamment
par le rassemblement national avec
lequel vous avez à former une union
même question pourquoi les habitants de
saint germain doivent-ils voté pour vous
le 15 mars
alors bonjour écoutez non pas qu'ils le
doivent ils le peuvent
on est on se présente tout d'abord parce
que moi je suis un amoureux de la vie de
saint germain en laye depuis très
longtemps et je crois que c'est le cas
je pense pouvoir l'affirmer pour eux
c'est le cas tous les candidats sur
notre liste d'union
quel est notre démarche notre démarche
est eux s'étaient initialement de se
réunir tous avec nos sensibilités
politiques différentes
voilà on reviendra au d'horizons
différents avec des étiquettes
politiques pour certains sans étiquette
politique pour d'autres l'idée c'était
de faire une liste d'union pour défendre
un projet local avec des convictions
communes
voilà à partir de ce moment là on s'est
rendu compte que il y avait une
nécessité de défendre un modèle saint
germanois ce qu'on appelle nous le bien
vivre parce qu'on estime qu'il est en
danger
voilà et donc on a fait des propositions
dans tous les domaines pour pouvoir
maintenir et protéger ce modèle de bien
vivre à saint germain alexandre grever
tête de liste unie pour agir saint
germes en lait pour que si votre aussi
première expérience en tant que candidat
pour les municipales vous avez été
engagées auparavant seine-saint-denis à
aulnay-sous-bois docteur en droit vous
êtes inspecteur des finances publiques
vous ne bénéficiez vous d'aucun soutien
politique de qu'un parti pour pour ces
élections pourquoi les électeurs doivent
t'ils voté pour vous le 15 mars
tout d'abord je vous remercie pour avoir
organisé ce débat puisque c'est vrai que
depuis quelques années à saint germain
ça manque beaucoup
la démocratie est l'occasion de pouvoir
échanger entre nous si aujourd'hui je
mène une liste divers droite et de
société civile c'est à dire avec des
personnalités qui pourront accompagner
dans le projet que nous proposons pour
saint germain et pour four que c'est
d'abord pour incarner le renouvellement
dont nous n'avons dont nous avons besoin
dans notre commune nouvelle puisque qui
dit comme une nouvelle dit évidemment
nouveau maire est donc ça sera au saint
germanois efforts que vient de décider
dans quelques jours de leur avenir pour
les six prochaines années et je m'engage
à leurs côtés à 100% chaque jour au
quotidien avec mes colistiers arnaud
péricard à tête de liste union pour
saint germain pour que vous êtes
actuellement
maire de la ville de saint germain
depuis 2010 est vous avez été élu par le
conseil municipal suite au décès d'
emmanuel lamy
vous vous déclarez indépendant soutenu
par de nombreux partis tout de même dont
la république en marche et les
républicains vous avez aussi créé le
mouvement génération terrain
rappelons aussi que vous êtes le fils de
l'ancien maire de la ville michel peiry
40 ans vous êtes avocat aux barreaux de
paris et de new york pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous accorder à
nouveau leur confiance dans une dizaine
de jours maintenant déjà merci de nous
avoir invités pour ce débat ce débat qui
doit s'articuler autour de deux projets
et d'une vision que nous avons pour
notre ville je crois que nous avons tous
les quatre ici cette ville en partager
en patient pourquoi que nous avons un
facteur commun
alors pourquoi les électeurs doivent
t'ils où pourrait-il nous faire
confiance je crois que nous avons à
coeur justement dans le projet que
j'aurais peut-être la chance d'exposer
tout à l'heure d'avoir un beau projet
pour cette ville que nous avons envie de
poursuivre autour d'eux peut-être trois
mots clés l'expérience qui est la nôtre
la crédibilité de nos propositions
elles sont toutes financés sans
augmentation de la pression fiscale et
de l'ambition que nous avons pour saint
germain en est voilà pour ce premier
tour de table merci à vous tous
on passe à présent différentes
thématiques qui vont structurer ce débat
avec vos temps de parole aussi qui
s'activent dans un premier temps vous
étaient tous à peu près à égalité
monsieur benz quelques secondes d'avancé
mais ça va se régler largement sur ce
débat on va commencer avec
l'environnement sujet devenu majeur dans
cette campagne un peu importe les villes
saint germain les bénéficie d'un cadre
de vie exceptionnel avec près de trois
quarts de son territoire occupé par une
forêt c'est aussi une ville bordée par
la seine au nord et un centre urbain qui
se concentrent dans le sud de la ville
alors que près prévoyez-vous chacun pour
l'environnement local et lutter à la
hauteur d'une ville si c'est possible au
dérèglement climatique
on commence avec vous alexandre grever
vous voulez faire de saint germes en
lait pour que le poumon écologique du
grand paris là je cite un ce qu'est ce
qui est inscrit sur sur votre site
internet tout à fait comme vous l'avez
cité tout à l'heure je n'ai pas grandi à
saint germain quand on arrive à saint
germain pour des raisons assez évidente
compte tenu de la qualité nos
établissements scolaires
le cadre de vie on se dit une chose
lorsqu'on vient d'où j'ai grandi c'est
surtout ne changez rien ne changeait
rien car on vit dans une ville
magnifique et aujourd'hui
malheureusement depuis quelques années
les choses c'est rod l'urbanisme est au
centre de ces campagnes et je ne veux
pas délié la question de l'environnement
notre cadre de vie quant à l'avenir de
l'urbanisation de notre ville
dès mon élection au lendemain je
convoquerai des états généraux
l'urbanisme afin de pouvoir mettre
autour de la table à la fois les
associations de riverains
les professionnels du bâtiment les
associations de protection de
l'environnement et celle de valorisation
du patrimoine pour que nous mettions à
la fois un terme à cette politique de
construction et pour animer notre
volonté d'une promotion réhabilitation à
la fois de notre centre-ville mais aussi
de nos quartiers excentrés résidentiel
qui est notre poumon urbain arnaud
péricard a forcément pour ce débat vous
allez être souvent interpellé libre à
vous de répondre à chaque fois en tant
que maire sortant en tout cas sur votre
programme pour l'environnement vous
proposer la création de nouveaux espaces
végétalisés en ville et de surfaces
urbaines et des âmes perméabilité
je n'ai pas loupé le mot c'est l'une de
vos propositions
alors c'est une proposition importante
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
particularité de notre territoire
communal c'est qu'il est composé à 75%
des espaces forestiers forêt de
saint-germain et forêt de marly
également et je crois qu'il faut
poursuivre le classement forêt de
protection et l'étendre sur la forêt de
marly demande et le défi qui se pose à
nous demain c'est comment faire en sorte
que cette nature qui nous entoure qui
nous encerclent comment elle vient
pénétrer interpénétrés le milieu urbain
qu'est le nôtre
pas toujours simple quand on a un
secteur sauvegardé je rappelle qu'il ya
quatre secteurs sauvegardés en
ile-de-france le 7e arrondissement le
marais versailles et saint germain donc
forcément ça contre 1 et donc
effectivement ce sont tous ces
engagements que nous avons déjà
contractualisé avec l' agence de l'eau
treize mille mètres carrés par an de
dessin perméabilité et sol c'est trop
compliqué à prononcer ce mot et plus de
dix mille mètres carrés pour végétaliser
de nouveaux espaces
en zone urbaine notamment sur la zone
dite de l'hôpital mais aussi là où nous
le pourrons dans l'espace que ça veut
dire moins de voitures en ville ça veut
dire à terme alors ça vous fait la
transition avec la révolution des
mobiliers des mobilités douces dans
laquelle nous allons nous engager avec
l'arrivée du thé très je pense qu'on
aura peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler
mais bien évidemment l'objectif c'est
d'avoir moins de véhicules dans l'hyper
centre et dans le centre du caire
richard c'est un sujet qui vous est
aussi forcément cher l'environnement
vous avez de nombreuses mesures parmi
elles trente kilomètres heure dans toute
l'agglomération aussi un territoire à
zéro déchet alors comment on devient un
territoire zéro déchet alors combien
comment on devient un territoire zéro
déchet il ya une action d'une part
auprès des commerçants c'est à dire
qu'on peut inciter aujourd'hui les
commerçants à franchir des contenants
réutilisables auprès des consommateurs
on peut prendre un arrêté pour interdire
l'utilisation du jetable sur la voie
publique
mais le zéro déchet je dirais ce n'est
qu'un des leviers qu'on doit utiliser
pour mener une véritable transition
écologique dans la ville transition
écologique qui ne peut se limiter à la
question de la préservation du cadre de
vie puisque c'est de cela qu'il a été
question jusqu'à présent on doit
envisager effectivement la question des
mobilités en mettant en question henry
questionnant la place de la voiture en
ville pour nous ça passe par des assises
locales de la mobilité en associant les
différents partenaires institutionnels
économiques associatifs il faut dire que
cette place de la voiture en ville elle
a été elle a été institutionnalisé à
saint germain aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
milliers de places de stationnement en
surface et en parcs de stationnement et
on pourrait on aurait pu avoir dans le
cadre de projets comme le tram très
express on aurait pu imaginer par
exemple un parking relais et aujourd'hui
on amène encore des voitures en ville
par exemple dans le quartier de
l'hôpital on a un nouveau parc de
stationnement qui est prévu et qui vient
alimenter ce centre commercial de plein
air quel centre ville de saint jérôme
alors la place de la voiture en ville je
vous propose qu'on en parle tout de
suite après ce premier tour de table et
vos propositions a avoué christophe
bentz pour l'environnement là aussi j'ai
noté quelques points créer un pôle de
l'environnement avec les partenaires de
la ville du coup avec qui et pour faire
quoi
alors la première chose dans
l'introduction c'est que je pense que
c'est très bien que
l'écologie se retrouve la défense de
l'environnement se retrouvent dans
toutes les listes et j'avais dans tous
les mouvements tous les partis parce que
je pense que le la défense de
l'environnement est tellement important
importante pardon qu'elle ne peut pas
appartenir à un seul parti politique et
ne peut pas être emprisonnée par un
corps on a effectivement plusieurs
propositions
on a décliné sur les questions
environnementales mais la première chose
que je voulais dire c'est que tout
d'abord ce qu'on souhaite c'est arrêté
comment dirais-je arrêter les la
continuation l'urbanisme et la
densification urbaine
on souhaite absolument stabiliser la
population parce qu'il ya un lien entre
l'urbanisme et la défense de
l'environnement on peut pas d'un côté
dire on va faire le singe armand une
ville avec 6000 habitants de plus en six
ans et dire qu'elle sera écologique
c'est pas possible parce que il ya
évidemment beaucoup d'incidence est
vraiment le la mesure phare de notre de
notre projet ce d'abord d'arrêter la
densification urbaine
après effectivement créer créer un
aspect de pôle environnemental qui
mettent autour de la table tous les tous
les partis pour toutes les parties
prenantes je pense à la lnf a la ratp en
ile-de-france mobilité le département
par toutes les collectivités
un pôle qui réunit qui réunisse toutes
ces toutes ses parties prenantes qui
puisse prendre des décisions collectives
arnaud péricard vous avez été plus ou
moins interpellé par tous les candidats
sur l'urbanisation la place de la
voiture si vous souhaitez répondre sur
ces sujets ou d'autres non bon c'est le
jeu d'être un petit peu effectivement
chahuté sur un certain nombre de sujets
je pense que par rapport à ces sujets là
il faut être factuel faut donner des
chiffres
saint germain c'est 1000 habitants de
moins depuis dix ans donc je veux bien
qu'on parle de densification ici et là
mais la réalité des chiffres
elle elle ne trompe pas mais l'habitant
de - saint-germain 200 habitants de
moins à four que depuis depuis dix ans
également entre 2009 et 2019
vous savez depuis que je suis maire le 7
juin 2017
j'ai fait le tri tout à l'heure j'ai
regardé j'ai délivré pour environ 6
environ un permis de construire par
semaine en tous à peu près y compris les
rénovations les surélévations des tâches
ça peut arriver
160 logements neufs dont
pendant 130 dont 60 logements qui
conserve de la rénovation dit monuments
historiques alors la densification
je veux bien qu'on fasse peur aux gens
mais c'est pas sur la peur qu'on
construit un projet municipal
c'est sur un projet conçu un programme
donc la densification
quand vous prenez ce chiffre en tête
mille habitants de moins en disant ça
c'est la réalité des chiffres
on va on va peut-être continuer sur
cette sur ce sujet de l'environnement
alexandre grever il ya un sujet qui va
aussi restructurer l'avenir de saint
germes en laisser le projet qui a lieu
dans le quartier de l'hôpital quelle est
votre position là dessus il est il est
déjà lancé ce qu'il faut le stopper
revenir dessus
bien sûr que non c'est une opportunité
c'est une opportunité à condition que
l'on soit très vigilant
je crois qu'on a besoin de capacités
stationnement pour notre centre ville là
où il faut et vais évidemment limité les
écueils c'est que nous allons déplacer
notre centre-ville à proximité du
carrefour du bel air ce carrefour quelle
est ta jonction des deux nationale où
circulent quarante mille véhicules par
jour voire même davantage
et là on a une vraie difficulté c'est à
dire que on va en avoir une influence
supplémentaire de véhicules avec
évidemment du résidentiel mais également
des activités commerciales à commencer
par un cinéma alors c'est très bien
personne malheureusement on regrettera
l'actuel cinéma et on sera très content
de pouvoir retrouver les visages qui
nous émerveille à l'accueil du ses deux
ailes pour pouvoir nous accueillir dans
le futur cinéma du quartier de l'hôpital
néanmoins il va falloir évidemment
pouvoir compter sur un afflux de
véhicules supplémentaires et est ce que
le stationnement sera suffisant et est
ce que on a vraiment besoin de cette
affluence supplémentaire
kane richard comment comment réduit la
place de la voiture puisque vous le
point thiais en début d'émission
alors aujourd'hui on a d'autres formes
de mobilité c'est à dire que la voiture
individuelle
certes à la vocation est moins présente
la vocation est de partager le
covoiturage et l'autopartage il ya faire
une vraie place aux piétons et aux vélos
en ville
alors il ya déjà une politique qui a été
initiée dans le cadre du plan vélo par
la communauté d'agglomération mais on
peut aller encore plus loin
aujourd'hui pour faciliter les liaisons
notamment entre quartiers si je prends
le carrefour du bel air qui a été évoqué
voilà on a dit discontinuité du point de
vue piétons et
point de vue vélo qui font
qu'aujourd'hui on laisse pas de la place
aux autres formes de mobilité sur saint
germain est sûre pour que christophe
bentz vous avez un peu de retard si vous
souhaitiez peut-être ajouter quelque
chose sur cette question de la mobilité
où on enchaîne sur le sujet suivant la
culture d'être une petite remarque
l'idée c'est pas on parlait d'écologie
c'est de ne pas comment dirais-je de
faire de l'écologie punitive
il faut que l'écologie est intelligent
c'est à dire que c'est pas les
circulations douces contre l'automobile
l'averse non plus l'idée c'est de
trouver un plan d' équilibre en plan de
circulation d équilibre entre toutes ces
mobilités qui voilà qui sont
complémentaires
c'est tout ce que je voulais ajouter des
sujets majeurs du coup qui va façonner
l'avenir de saint germain en laye et
puis je le disais de toutes les communes
et des yvelines de l'ile-de-france de la
france entière évidemment c'est
l'environnement
je vous propose trouve pas ça un sujet
est là pour le coup qui est très
atypique à saint germes en laisser c'est
la culture dans ce débat qui est
diffusée sur tv 78 radio sensations la
culture saint germain les cité royale
louis xiv est né à saint germain en laye
pour ceux qui ne le savent pas la paix
avec l'autriche a été signé au lendemain
de la première guerre mondiale en 1919 à
saint germain en laye de nombreux
artistes intellectuels et auteurs ont
séjourné dans la commune la culture
l'histoire le patrimoine sont partout
dans cette ville atypique des yvelines
avec musées médiathèques ou encore le
théâtre alexandre dumas du coup je
voulais avoir vos positions là dessus on
va reprendre avec vous christophe bentz
vous souhaitez développer des projets
touristiques
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
l'idée c'est de mettre en valeur encore
davantage le patrimoine historique de la
ville qui effectivement vous l'avez
souligné est très riche
je trouve que c'est dommage que l'on ne
bénéficie pas plus du tourisme est il
retombé et qui pourrait être très
positif a notamment pour l'économie des
pros des projets gens on en propose déjà
plusieurs et notamment un qui le tient
particulièrement à coeur ce serait de
d'organiser annuellement espèce de grand
rendez vous autour de l'histoire de la
ville de saint-germain-en-laye autour
d'un spectacle ou un grand spectacle
vous dites à rendez-vous au monumental
c'est noir anderson monumentale en fait
ça peut prendre deux formes
je vous donne deux exemples très simple
soit ça peut être un grand spectacle son
et lumière sur la façade du château par
exemple quand il sera quand les travaux
seront terminés
un petit peu à l'image de ce qui se fait
aux invalides sont aimés rosa valide
voire même
un spectacle vivant qui pourrait être
organisée un peu sur le modèle de la
cinéscénie la cinéscénie pardon du puy
du fou
voilà un grand spectacle qui sera qui
serait peut-être de valorisation de
l'histoire de la ville alexandre grever
vous proposez vous par exemple d'ouvrir
les bibliothèques plus longtemps et plus
souvent et se trouvent aussi les acteurs
culturels et historiques de la ville oui
comment alors d'une part déjà on parlait
des bibliothèques et c'est vrai que nous
sommes un territoire qui est riche
d'équipements qui sont d'un très bon
niveau alors aussi bien la médiathèque
mais également la bibliothèque du
quartier du bel air malheureusement pour
celle ci notamment elle n'est pas
ouverte suffisamment c'est à dire que
pour pouvoir organiser l'éveil à la
lecture pour pouvoir regagner organisé
un certain nombre d'événements
je crois qu'on ne peut pas se satisfaire
de ces 28 heures par semaine
hebdomadaire d'ouverture dans le
quartier du bel air et qui évidemment il
va falloir réorganiser les plages
d'ouverture pour pouvoir avoir une
ouverture quotidienne à partir de 16h30
le mercredi
également samedi comme aujourd'hui tout
à fait mais ce n'est pas la seule chose
je crois qu'en matière de culture il va
falloir aussi que l'on défende nos
atouts à commencer par le conservatoire
de musique en le préservant en centre
ville
dane richards vos propositions avouait
elle mentionne notamment la création
d'une nouvelle salle de concert dans le
quartier du bel air et une saison de
concerts en plein air gratuit aussi donc
ça j'imagine que c'est plutôt pour les
beaux jours
alors oui nous la question de la culture
on la lit à la question de l'équité
sociale c'est à dire qu'on pense que
toutes et tous doivent avoir accès à la
culture que l'offre culturelle notamment
sur les équipements déjà existants de la
ville si on parle de la programmation du
théâtre alexandre dumas ça doit être une
programmation qui doit être accessible à
la fois en termes de programmation mais
également en termes de tarifs
et puis c'est une offre aussi qu'ils
doivent être répartis dans la ville
notamment sur le sur le quartier du bel
air le déplacement du conservatoire à
rayonnement départemental au bel air
nous on n'y a absolument pas opposé
on pense que ça devrait se doubler
d'ailleurs d'un projet de salle de
concert en tout cas alain baudin nouvel
équipement culturel pour
amener la culture dans le quartier du
bel air arnaud péricard vous mentionnez
vous la rénovation des bâtiments
culturels et du patrimoine culturel ça a
déjà été soulevé c'est un point
important de votre programme pour la
culture c'est un point important c'est
aussi de notre responsabilité communale
on a parlé du théâtre mais je rappelle
que vous vient d'engager trois millions
et demi d'euros dans la rénovation
notamment des fresques de notre église
de notre paroisse ce que nous allons
également continuer ce travail là sur
l'église sainte-croix à fourques eux qui
est aussi patrimoine communal vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure à juste titre la
vitalité la richesse de notre vie
culturelle mais il n'ya pas que le
conservatoire il ya aussi la clé qui est
peut-être l'un des acteurs culturels le
plus important sur le territoire et moi
je suis comme vous l'avez dit monsieur
richard très favorable puisque c'est le
projet que je porte j'étais maire
adjoint à la culture à l'époque du
déménagement de ce conservatoire qui de
toutes les manières n'est plus aux
normes
aujourd'hui et qui n'est plus inclusif
il faut aussi penser à l'accès à la
culture pour tous et on a si on veut
rééquilibrer l'offre d'équipements
culturels entre le nord et le sud de
saint germain il faut absolument que
l'on s'engage sur ce projet qui est un
très beau progrès et qui va permettre
notamment de réunir et la chorégraphie
et les arts dramatiques et la musique
avec peut-être pas une salle de
spectacle n'est en tout cas une salle
pour les ensembles musicaux 150 200
places il faudra qu'on définit si on en
parlera à tous ensemble la volumétrie de
cet espace christophe bentz vous
souhaitiez réagir juste pour terminer
sur la question du patrimoine je pense
qu'il ya urgence
évidemment à continuer les rénovations
notamment des églises mais aussi le
coeur de ville pour avoir habité
longtemps rue du vieil abreuvoir est
rude et coach je peux vous dire
qu'effectivement le bâti est en très
mauvais état et il ya franchement
urgence d'ailleurs on l'a vu avec les
les fondations qui souvent remonte au
16e 15e voir 14e siècle même si ça n'est
rénové entre temps les fondations sont
très anciennes et donc il a
effectivement urgence à sauver le
patrimoine du coeur historique
kane richard vous avez un peu de retard
sur les autres au niveau du temps de
parole peut être évoqué un autre point
de votre programme culturel g le témoin
le créer une nouvelle médiathèque
alors effet il y en a déjà deux
existants dire sur la médiathèque alors
nous ce que nous proposions c'est que
dans le cadre du projet coeur des
sources on dispose d'un équipement en
tout cas au bel air
qu'ils soient d'un niveau de qualité de
service qui est celui de la médiathèque
du centre-ville et qu'on transforme
l'actuelle médiathèque donc ils seront
vos bel air en ludothèque parce que
c'est un équipement qui nous est demandé
qu' une attente des jeunes de la ville
on a aussi pour ambition portée la
création d'une université populaire on a
une université libre à saint germain
mais qui s'adresse à un public un petit
peu différent avec des heures en journée
et là c'est l'idée ce serait d'apporter
de la culture accessible à tous et
surtout les quartiers de la ville 1
voilà autant de paroles vont s'afficher
en à peu près tout le monde a à quatre
minutes on s'approche de la moitié de ce
débat déjà on va évoquer la thématique
du social thématique assez large qui va
vous permettre à chacun de l'aborder
sous l'angle souhaité logements seniors
santé précarité
à vous de faire votre choix quelques
indications aussi pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le territoire mais saint
germain en laye n'est pas dans une
situation sociale qu'on pourrait
qualifier de compliquer le taux de
pauvreté selon l'insee de 8 % contre 10
% en moyenne dans le département est des
yvelines vos propositions sur le sujet
kane richard on va on va reprendre avec
vous vous voulez renforcer l'action du
centre communal d'action sociale
notamment est allé jusqu'à 30% aussi de
logements sociaux alors ça passe
effectivement par la consolidation de
l'action du ccas le logement social
alors saint germain est plutôt un bon
élève mais on pense qu'on peut aller
plus loin qu'on doit couvrir différents
types de logements donc effectivement il
ya le logement social il ya le logement
intermédiaire et c'est aussi l'idée que
ce logement il doit être ce logement
social doit être répartie sur l'ensemble
des quartiers de la ville on porte aussi
la question de l'habitat participatif de
l'habitat inclusif est en tout cas ce
qu'on ambitionne nous c'est de créer une
vraie mixité sociale qui aujourd'hui
n'existe pas à saint germain 30 % de
logements sociaux
ça veut dire de nouvelles constructions
de nouvelles constructions mais ça peut
être aussi un droit de préemption qui
exercé par la ville sur certains
immeubles
alors j'ai eu du mal à me procurer le
chiffre du taux de logements sociaux
dans la ville donc je me tourne vers on
est quelques jours que 25 22 5la la loi
impose
2 500 en en 2000 en 2025 c'est ça
christophe ben sur le social voulez-vous
à développer des lieux de vie et
événements inter-générationnelle puisque
là aussi vous pouvez nous donner des
exemples concrets con qu'on pourrait
voir le jour qui pourrait voir le jour
sur le territoire
l'idée c'est de développer le lien entre
les jeunes et les anciennes générations
pour qu'elles puissent se parler pour
qu'elles puissent échanger
nous trouvons qu'il ya peu de lieux pour
ça il ya peu d'événements dédiés à ça ne
dit pas qu'il ya pas d événement pour
les seniors mais des dvd le vrai
événement intergénérationnel pour que
voilà les générations puissent mieux se
connaître sur le territoire de saint
germain en laye sur la question du
social pour moi il sait aussi la
question de l'éducation et des familles
j'insiste beaucoup sur un point saint
germain en laye est une ville très
familial je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui est fait pour les familles on
peut aller encore plus loin
il ya notamment une carence en matière
d'offre sur la petite enfance ne serait
ce que sur la question des places en
crèche c'est pas un mince sujet c'est
pas 1 1 ce sujet et je pense que il faut
absolument qu'on fasse un audit rapide
d'ailleurs on propose nous un plan qu'on
a qu'on a intitulé saint germain 2030
un audit général qui balaye l'ensemble
des sujets qu'ils puissent faire un état
des lieux des structures de l'offre de
la demande des besoins des 40 c
voilà pour proposer une vision à long
terme notamment et en particulier pour
défendre les familles qui vont bien la
difficulté à sa rejoint comme ailleurs
arnaud péricard aux propositions dans le
domaine social peut être sur cette
question du manque de de place pour les
600 places
aujourd'hui à saint germain parce que
notre estimation c'est que ce chiffre là
suffit aujourd'hui alors après ça dépend
évidemment de la démographie sa
dépendent de la natalité dont qu'il ait
jamais interdits de toutes les manières
de revoir vous savez la gestion
municipale celle contre une gestion
pragmatique et on s'adapte aux
circonstances et aux évolutions
simplement très rapidement sur le
logement ce que je voulais vous dire
donc 22h30 % de logements sociaux je
crois qu'on est quasiment en maturité
donc moi je ne suis pas tout à fait
favorable à monter ce seuil à 30 % je
crois qu on y est on est un petit peu
à notre seuil d'équilibré il ya deux
plans importants de rénovation de
l'habitat social que nous allons engager
celui à côté de l'hôpital la cité large
et et puis celui de la cité caraman qui
est à proximité du nouveau quartier ou
de ce projet de réhabilitation dudit du
du coeur des sources et puis il ya aussi
faut pas l'oublier que son gouvernement
est une ville militaire une ville de
garnison
il ya presque deux mille cinq cents
personnes qui travaillent personnels
civils et militaires de la défense au
camp des loges à gallieni et qui vivent
ce sont plusieurs centaines de logements
militaires il faut que l'on s'engage
également avec la direction immobilière
du ministère de la défense dans un vaste
plan de réhabilitation de logements
militaires ça c'est également important
alexandre grever sur la thématique
sociale j'ai noté créer une nouvelle
maison de santé en centre ville est
alors hyper simplifier les démarches
administratives des usagers grâce au
numérique
je vous donner un chiffre 40% des saint
germanois d'aujourd'hui n'habitait pas
saint germain il ya cinq ans aujourd'hui
c'est notre attractivité dont dépend un
certain nombre de projets que l'on doit
mettre en place dans les six prochaines
années nous sommes dans un environnement
de concurrence territoriale la qualité
de nos établissements scolaires demain
on peut s'attendre à ce qu'elles soient
maintenues mais on a besoin de compléter
notre offre pour notamment pour des
familles des familles qui sont de plus
en plus éloignés de leur propre famille
donc notamment la maison de santé nous
allons avoir le quartier de l'hôpital
dans cinq ou six ans nous ne pouvons pas
attendre
nous ne pouvons pas attendre plus de la
moitié de nos médecins généralistes ont
plus de 55 ans on voit la menace
aujourd'hui ses médecins généralistes
ils sont installés essentiellement en
centre-ville
nous installons prioritairement dans
l'année où les 18 mois de début de
mandat une maison de santé dédiée aux
généralistes pour accueillir des jeunes
généralistes mais également permettre à
d'anciens généraliste de lever le pied
et d'accompagner les jeunes pour pouvoir
offrir ce premier maillon de
sécurisation de l'offre de soins aux
familles et deuxième chose également
pour les familles le diagnostic nous
l'avons fait en matière d'accueil
notamment la petite enfance
ce dont nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
c'est d'expérimenter une garderie pour
la petite enfance le samedi
parce que de plus en plus de parents
sont sollicités professionnellement pour
travailler le samedi
beaucoup également mène une formation
professionnelle qui leur prend du temps
personnel et nous avons besoin les
accompagner et c'est le rôle de la
municipalité c'est le rôle du maire
évidemment cas il n'y arrive pas c'est
vrai que c'était un sujet à aborder par
tous les candidats cette question de la
santé
quelle est votre position est ce que
vous avez une proposition forte pour les
six prochaines années si vous êtes élu
alors se met effectivement aussi
favorable à la mise en place d'une
maison de santé à saint germain en laye
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui d'une
difficulté à trouver un médecin
généraliste et qui plus est des
généralistes et des spécialistes
conventionnés de secteur 1 il y en a pas
tant que ça sur saint germain en laye et
qui prennent de nouveaux patients donc
effectivement c'est c'est quelque chose
qui s'impose en je ne sais pas si vous
souhaitiez aussi réagir sur la dessus
sachant que vous êtes un peu en avance
du coup le temps de parole sera sera
moindre pour vous sur la fuite et à
l'air vous utiliserez votre temps de
parole
ensuite on passe du coup à la démocratie
et sujet là aussi très très important
depuis la crise ddj les jeux notamment à
serge eyrolles a enlevé il ya sept
conseils de quartier pour s'informer ou
s'exprimer
il est aussi un conseil municipal junior
pour initier les plus les futurs
électeurs à l'investissement dans la vie
locale
et puis il y eut un sujet aussi qui a
nourri quelques tensions s'étaient la
fusion avec pour que le 1er janvier 2019
ce rapprochement historique sera
finalement acté après ces élections avec
l'élection cette fois ci d'un seul
conseil municipal et de 45 élus vos
propositions sur sur le sujet pour
nourrir la démocratie dans cette
nouvelle commune arnaud péricard vous
voulez créer de nouveau conseil
consultatif citoyen pour le commerce de
proximité notamment et pour le
développement durable
oui on appelle ça les conseils locaux on
n'en avait créés on était la première
ville en france à créer un conseil local
du numérique et je pense que c'est une
expérience qui a bien marché ça permet
de tirer profit un peu de l'intelligence
collective de nos habitants et on
souhaite faire de même
conseil local du développement durable
dotés de budgets autonomes espèce de
comité d'audit sur toutes nos politiques
et nos pratiques environnementales et la
même chose sur le commerce de proximité
parce que je pense qu'il est important
que les consommateurs est également leur
mot à dire sur le commerce
alexandre grever vous souhaitez vous
pour la démocratie crée des conseils
aussi alors je ne sais pas si c'est tout
fait pareil décisionnel de quartier
formé de moitié d'élus moitié
d'habitants quel pouvoir pour ses
conseils du coup vient après l'épisode
de la fusion qui a été dramatique pour
notre démocratie locale il faut bien
l'avouer ont sonné à échanger avec
arnaud péricard et moi sur cette
question nous ne sommes pas tombés
d'accord je n'ai pas réussi à le
convaincre sur la nécessité d'organiser
un référendum qui aurait permis au moins
de trancher la question est aujourd'hui
ce que l'on voit c'est que il faut
rendre les clés de la ville aux
habitants est la meilleure manière c'est
de se servir de ces quartiers de nos
quartiers de lait transformés en
conseils décisionnel afin de les doter
d'un petit budget participatif à leur
budget petit budget c'est pas forcément
très modeste mais qu'ils puissent se
consacrer aux investissements de
proximité c'est aux habitants qu'ils
connaissent très bien leur quartier de
décider des investissements qui doivent
embellir et améliorer leur quartier
christophe bentz sur la démocratie
vous êtes vous vous refusez de nouvelles
fusions et pas de remise en cause de
celle acté avec pour que du coup alors
pas de fusion forcée
on se pose effectivement à des fusions
qu'ils soient forcés celle de defour que
l'est je suis pas du tout opposé par
principe à la fusion de communes à deux
conditions
la première c'est qu'elle soit
l'initiative des communes et qu'elles ne
soient pas imposées par l'état la
deuxième condition c'est que les
populations en soient d'accord
c'est pour ça qu'on propose un
référendum local maintenant oui a
posteriori de la fusion pour consulter
enfin la population réussi si le
référendum s'oppose à la fusion vous
ferez tout pour revenir sur cette fusion
absorption
ça s'appelle à des fusions ça existe il
ya des communes en france qui ont déjà
défusionnées ça existe mais c'est à la
population de fort que de déterminer et
donc de ceux d'être consultés
dane richards peut-être sur ce sujet de
la fusion on le voit cristallise encore
les débats ou sur d'autres sujets vous
composé notamment un budget participatif
de 5% vous n'êtes pas le seul
mais vous c'est 2 5% alors effectivement
oui je pense que
tout le monde a compris aujourd'hui il y
aurait dû y avoir un référendum pour la
fusion à four que d'ailleurs nous nous
engageons pour les prochaines fusion de
communes à organiser un référendum local
donc c'est à dire que vous êtes
favorable à de nouvelles fusions on est
favorable à l'utilisation du référendum
local pour poser la question de
l'intérêt de la fusion pour les
habitants concernés
donc on a comme outil le budget
participatif
les conseils de quartier on porte aussi
un comité citoyen qu'il a et un comité
citoyen environnement et climat et dont
l'objet sera d'interroger chacune des
décisions prises par la municipalité en
fonction son impact sur le climat
surtout ce qui est conseil de quartier
conseils communaux consultatifs locaux
nous ce qu'on pense c'est que les modes
de désignation doit être clair ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui c'est que quand on
habite un quartier à saint germain en
laye voilà on sait pas nécessairement
comment est désigné son conseil de
quartier quand est-ce qu'il se tient est
ce qui se tient régulièrement
voilà nous pensons qu'il doit y avoir
plus de transparence à ce niveau là on
demande également à ce que la présidence
de la commission d'appel d'offres soit
confié un élu d'opposition
tous ces outils qui font que la
démocratie fonctionne dans une commune
comme saint germain en laye arnaud
péricard vous êtes forcément viser sur
ce manque de démocratie avec ce sujet de
fusion absorption des visées par le
manque de démocratie je pense que j'ai
fait et y compris notamment monsieur
pascal lévêque a été élu conseiller
communautaire sur ma liste donc on peut
pas dire que je suis particulièrement
visés par le manque de démocratie qui
voulait simplement revenir très
tranquillement les très sereinement sur
cet épisode de la fusion moi je sens
quand même un petit peu jen a vis-à-vis
deux des trois autres candidats je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être sortir de la
confusion
si demain vous êtes élu est-ce que vous
défusionnées ou est-ce que vous
poursuivez ce processus que nous avons
mis en place il ya maintenant 15 mois
qui fonctionne bien
un chiffre 1300 actes d'état civil qui
sont aujourd'hui depuis cet été fait à
l'hôtel de ville de fourqueux ce qui
n'était pas possible avant et plein
d'autres est ce que demain vous allez
scier les mâts des caméras de vidéo
protection est ce que vous allez revenir
sur le fait que la police municipale
patrouillent dans les rues de
pour que demain est ce que vous allez
revenir sur le bio que nous avons mis en
place à la cantine
moi je pense que ça serait bien que les
électeurs et peut-être davantage de
précisions dans votre programme vous
n'en parlez pas justement et c'est un
petit peu le dénominateur commun que
vous avez tous les trois mais je crois
que et les spectateurs les auditeurs et
les électeurs auraient le droit c'est un
monsieur s'est prononcé sur le sujet
pour alexandre grever votre position est
ce que selon vous il faut revenir sur
cette fusion alors je n'ai pas préparé
évidemment l'émission avec monsieur
péricarde mais c'est vrai que ce sujet a
cristallisé beaucoup les tensions
pendant quelques semaines quelques mois
vous en parlait tous du coup votre
position là dessus il faut changer de
méthode je crois clairement la première
conséquence de cette fusion ça a été
créé un contentieux canton ce qui a
devant le juge administratif
donc attendons de savoir ce que le juge
administratif dira et puis nous en
tirons les conséquences et nous nous
adapterons voilà je crois qu'il faut
être pragmatique tout était coincé
bah écoutez clairement si monsieur benz
et monsieur richard veulent attendre
l'issue du de ce contentieux pour
s'engager dans la gestion de la ville
les prochaines élections sont là moi
clairement je suis là pour être
opérationnel tout de suite tout de suite
et les fourquésiens sont bien présents
également sur notre liste divers droite
et société civile pour pouvoir les
représenter avancée sur les projets qui
les anime en leur quartier leur village
kane richard vous voulez aussi j'ai noté
des référendums locaux sur quel sujet
les sujets du référendum local ça peut
être par exemple des sujets qui
n'auraient pas été présentées avant le
mandat dans le cadre d'une campagne
électorale des sujets qui sont nouveaux
sur lesquels les citoyens se sont pas
prononcés dans le cadre d'un scrutin
des sujets qui sont déçus et des sujets
structurants pour l'avenir de la commune
également donc ça vise par exemple une
éventuelle fusion
ça peut être une éventuelle fusion ça
peut être des projets / / / des
quartiers par exemple le quartier de
l'hôpital christophe bentz vous avez un
peu de un peu de retard pour terminer
sur cette question de la démocratie
voulait empêcher de nouveaux transferts
de compétences vers l'intercommunalité
c'est un sujet aussi très important pour
les années à venir
on a vu le poids des intercommunalités
s'agrandir
ces six dernières années est ce que ça
veut dire qu'ils avaient de nouveau
transfert qui était prévu ça c'est le
problème beaucoup plus générale que ça
aujourd'hui et là je vais sortir
quelques instants de des frontières
saint germanoise on change de modèle
c'est à dire que le modèle traditionnel
qui a structuré le l'organisation
territoriale française a été fondée sur
la commune le département et la nation
et on voit que tous ces échelons là sont
j'avais dit à éclater un par un au
bénéfice d'intercommunalité toujours
plus grande est toujours moins proche
des habitants au profit de grandes
régions d'euros région et au profit de
l'union européenne et de son système
donc en fait c'est un problème de modèle
général moi je défends absolument le
modèle communal je pense que c'est
d'échelon d'efficacité politique le le
bleu le plus essentiel
en fait voilà et dernière chose sur la
question la démocratie je pense qu'un
mandat ce n'est pas un chèque en blanc
même si on est élu que ce soit monsieur
richard mme gervais où monsieur ferry
karuma même peu importe ce n'est pas un
chèque en blanc il faut consulter la
population
tout au long de la du mandat notamment
effectivement sur des sujets sur
lesquels on n'aurait pas débattu pendant
la campagne électorale municipale
on va passer sur la dernière thématique
de cette émission pour ce débat diffusé
sur tv 78 radio sensations la sécurité
vous en parlait tous plus ou moins de la
sécurité quelques chiffres 42 policiers
municipaux à saint germain en laye une
brigade de nuit aussi avec huit agents
la police municipale armée depuis 2016
vos propositions pour la sécurité arnaud
péricard je commence avec vous voulez
renforcer la police municipale est ce
que ça veut dire plus d'agents et si oui
combien la sécurité sur une ville c'est
une coproduction saint germain c'est une
zone police il ya plus d'une centaine de
fonctionnaires de la police nationale
il ya des gendarmes il ya la garde
républicaine et il ya également la
police municipale mais la sécurité dans
une ville ça n'est pas que la police
municipale alors évidemment nous y
contribuons fortement 43 agents et nous
avions pris avec emmanuel lamy la
décision d'armer notre police municipale
et à l'époque c'était une décision qui
était compliquée qui avait fait débat y
compris dans nos rangs mais je voulais
puisque le commissaire
visionnaire de saint germain m'a donné
les chiffres la semaine dernière
peut-être vous donner parce que je sais
qu'ici est là on va dire que on vit dans
un no man's land et que la situation
sécuritaire de son dès demain en
avant-première au jeu c'est voilà donc
moins 25% de délinquance ou voie
publique 2019 versus 2018 et -21%
d'atteintes aux biens simplement la
seule où le seul type ou le seul format
de délinquance qui augmente à saint
germain c'est la délinquance dite
électronique les fraudes et les arnaques
notamment dans les cartes de crédit
quand vous achetez ou quand vous avez
poésie propose sur internet et contre
ses tablettes électroniques non je ne
dépasse jamais pouvoir en sait un peu
mais a remarqué mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que cette coproduction sécuritaire
aujourd'hui elle fonctionne la ville est
confrontée aussi à ces difficultés les
chiffres sont là en tout la promenade
système alexandre grever la question de
la sécurité
ce périphérique et son insécurité c'est
pas une question de chiffres
c'est une question de personne mettez
des personnes derrière les chiffres
imaginer la souffrance que l'on peut
rencontrer à être agressés à être
menacée la sécurité c'est d'abord un
sentiment d'insécurité qui arrivent dans
les têtes c'est pourquoi nous proposons
que le poste de police municipale du
bel-air soient ouverts 24 heures sur 24
afin que chaque usager chaque habitant
et la possibilité de pouvoir pousser la
porte et avoir un accueil l'assistance
aux personnes est une mission
fondamentale de la police municipale
vous proposez aussi le zéro tolérance
face aux dégradations en ville c'est à
dire quoi zéro tolérance que celle
d'aujourd'hui quand on tolère des
incivilités surtout au niveau des
dégradations
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup des dépôts sauvages en forêt en
lisière de forêt mais il faut aussi
parler de ce qui arrive et qui
s'installe dans notre ville on a besoin
d'avoir une ville propre nous avons une
ville qui est malheureusement salle trop
sale et donc ce zéro tolérance c'est
aussi d'entretenir dans l'état d'esprit
dé saint germanois et des fours cozien
l'idée qu'ils vivent dans une ville
propre belle à la hauteur des impôts
qu'ils payent chaque année kane richard
sur cette thématique de la sécurité pour
être france
n'ai pas trouvé directement dans votre
programme électoral
alors effectivement nous la sécurité
nous ne voulons pas un thème central de
notre campagne contrairement à d'autres
d'autres candidats ce n'est pas un thème
que nous sous-estimons mais c'est pas un
thème que nous surestimons non plus elle
la sécurité ne peut reposer sur la vidéo
uniquement sur la vidéoprotection
c'est avant tout de l'humain il ya un
travail qui est fait aujourd'hui dans
les quartiers avec les acteurs socio
culturel avec des centres socioculturels
la soucoupe lagat sec
la présence de la mission locale il ya
un travail qui peut être fait avec les
bailleurs sociaux qui peut être
poursuivi
voilà nous on pense que c'est avant tout
une question humaine et sociale peut
être par plus de social effectivement
c'est une question d'équité sociale
d'abord et avant tout christophe bentz
je pense que vous ne partagez pas
forcément ce point de vue en tout cas
directement pour vous aussi vous parler
de tolérance zéro quelles questions
aussi enfin même question qu'est ce que
ça veut dire tolérance zéro et comment
on peut avoir une tolérance zéro pour
nous très clairement le sujet de la
sécurité il est central
effectivement là dessus on diverge il
est central et il est je dirais il est
grave et très franchement pour en avoir
parlé avec beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
saint germanois très récemment les ces
derniers jours je vais vous dire que au
delà des chiffres
au delà des chiffres il ya un vrai
sentiment d'insécurité mais ce n'est pas
qu'un sentiment il ya quand même une
croissance de la violence et de mort
c'est ce qu'on appelle la sauvage mans
il ya encore six mois on a eu quand même
des règlements de comptes au sabre dans
les rues de saint germain en laye donc
il ya eu des phénomènes graves violent
c'est une préoccupation majeure et je en
atteste pour la voir en encore une fois
parler avec beaucoup de saint germanois
qui sont très inquiet très inquiet donc
nous pour le coup c'est une thématique
très très importante
on a des propositions très claires on
propose d'augmenter encore les moyens
municipaux de police on propose un
policier armé pour 1000 habitants ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et on
produit et fresques avec 43 agents
municipaux on est à 45
on les a poussés à magenta jour me l'a
dit cas rare mais voilà l'armée
aujourd'hui en 46 policiers noirs mais
voilà exactement 45 aujourd'hui on a on
inclue dedans les agents administratifs
et les téléopérateurs de vidéoprotection
d'ailleurs sur la question de la vidéo
protection
on propose qu'elle soit vraiment une
vidéo protection parce que pour
l'instant elle ne couvre pas à 100% ça
ne couvre pas 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 365 jours par an il faut augmenter
le monde d'agents téléopérateurs qu'ils
surveillent
parce que si vous voulez être filmé en
train de se faire agresser ou se faire
braquer très bien on est content mais ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'il ya aussi des
agents sur le terrain même moment qu'ils
puissent agir et intervenir en opérer
car je voulais ce peut être réagir à ce
qui a été dit vous avez finalement très
peu de temps pour réagir s'ils voulaient
garder du temps pour la conclusion des
opérateurs de télésurveillance on en a
ça y est on en est embauchée et que on a
une surveillance 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 avec nos soixante dix bientôt 80
caméras de vidéoprotection sur tous les
opérateurs
très bien on voit vos positions sur le
sujet éventuelles et puis il ya aussi on
va voir à présent vos temps de parole
pour connaître le temps qu'il vous reste
pour cette conclusion avec monsieur
richard qui est un peu de retard donc
plus de temps pour conclure c'est
l'ordre inverse du coup du temps de
parole d'introduction arnaud péricard
vous débutez avec une minute quarante
neuf maximum je vais essayer de faire
cela en synthèse trois axes prioritaires
qui sont constitutifs de notre identité
a tous notre identité et saint
germanoise une ville de l'éducation et
des familles une ville nature baignée
par la nature et cette nature doit
pénétrer davantage notre tissu urbain et
puis une ville au rayonnement culturel
et patrimonial comme nulle autre
pareille de grands projets importants
celui de l'hôpital
on en a parlé celui du coeur des sources
et surtout l'ensemble des mesures que
nous portons l'ensemble de ce programme
est financé à travers une gestion
rigoureuse avec un endettement quasi nul
et puis avec une pression fiscale qui
restera constante nous n'avons pas
augmenté les impôts depuis 2011
nous n'allons pas les augmenter sur les
six prochaines années alexandre grever
une minute une minute trente au maximum
pour pour conclure pour pouvoir
concrétiser le renouvellement
que je porte avec mes colistiers nous
avons à coeur trois objectifs le premier
c'est de prendre soin prendre soin de
notre ville prendre soin de ses
habitants le second c'est de revitaliser
revitaliser notre offre culturelle nos
commerces et enfin c'est de préparer
l'avenir la question de l'écologie la
question du cadre de vie et centrale
c'est notre fille devers nous ce n'est
ni un ogre nine opportunité électorale
nous devons à chaque décision à chaque
projet réfléchir aux conséquences et aux
bienfaits que l'on peut mener au plus
près de la population
christophe benz pour la conclusion vous
avez a peut-être un peu moins de temps
que les autres une minute maximum
je vais faire très rapide mais trois
mots clés qu'on a choisi pour cette
campagne c'est cadre de vie sécurité a
peu parlé et attractivité cadre de vie
j'aurais parlé au tout début en
expliquant que nous pensons à avec notre
liste audace pour saint germain que le
modèle de bien vivre à saint germanois
est en danger il est en danger
aujourd'hui et ce dans tous les domaines
donc on souhaite le préserver on saute
de défendre absolument d'où toutes les
propositions que nous avons dans tous
les domaines la sécurité j'y reviens pas
j'en ai suffisamment parlé et
l'attractivité qu'elle soit économique
ou culturel
kane richard merci pour pour le temps de
par le key richard vous avez du coup un
peu plus de temps jusqu'à deux minutes
libre à vous d'en disposer ou non alors
oui nous voulons que vous rappelez les
thèmes qui sont importants pour nous la
transition écologique évidemment donc le
contexte de l'urgence climatique
nous vous ce que nous souhaitons c'est
pas une écologie des années 90 et 2000
qui est celle du tri sélectif et du
développement durable nous c'est une
notion d'écologie du zéro déchet de la
transition de la manière dont on prépare
un territoire à la résilience c'est la
question de l'équité sociale
effectivement pour nous ça passe par la
culture et ça c'est un axe évidemment
très important la participation de
toutes et tous à la vie locale
la question de la démocratie c'est le
sens de ce que nous avons fait avec
cette liste une liste citoyenne et où ce
programme nous l'avons bâtie à
l'occasion de réunions publiques
d'ateliers participatifs et ça dit
quelque chose je crois de la manière
dont on souhaite aujourd'hui
agir pour notre ville sur la question de
la sur la question de la démocratie
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat voilà quelques
quelques écarts assez assez minime ans
dans vos temps de parole mais je crois
que nous avons tous joué le jeu merci
beaucoup pour ce débat une nouvelle fois
j'invite aussi les téléspectateurs et
les auditeurs de radio sensations à
consulter notre site internet
vos meetings ils sont mentionnés et ils
peuvent aussi évidemment suivre la
campagne des élections municipales au
jour le jour sur tv 78 merci à tous
bonne soirée
[Musique]